[音楽]
[拍手]
まずはじめに
皆さんに一つこの質問させてください
皆さん人生楽しいですか
楽しいですか
僕ねーいま人生めっちゃ楽しいです
めっちゃしんどいです
この楽しい人生を僕今何を何に携わって生活をしているかと言うと
スポーツですハンドボールです
いやそれはハンドボール好きだからそれは楽しいでしょうなったって思う方もきっと
いるとは思うんですけどあの実を言うと僕
一番好きなスポーツはサッカーです
はい
まあただその好きだから楽しいんだよということではなくて違う観点があるから今僕が
楽しめてるんだよっていうところも今日お伝えできたらなと思っています
はい僕はドイツでハンドボール選手をしていました
ドイツのブンデスリーガあって言う
世界最高峰のリーグなんですけどそこでハンドボール選手として活動していました
なんでハンドボールを始めてドイツに行ったかっていうと
まあ本当に偶然に引っ越しした先にハンドボールできる場所があってそこを見に行っ
たらハンドボールがもしそうで初めてでその直後にドイツにはこういうプロのリーグ
なるんだよっていうのを聞いて
っといつ行ってやってみたいって本当に子供ながらの嫁
そんな感じですね
そんな風にして夢を持ちました
で大学在学時は僕ハンドボール度には所属してなかったんですけど
大学を卒業してドイツに
行けました入っちゃいました
行動力ハンパないなぁって思う人もいると思うんですけどあの僕実は本当に真逆の
タイプで
本当にミスをしたくなくて失敗しないようにどんだけも準備して準備して準備してそれ
をやるっていうくらい本当に慎重なタイプの人間だったんです
なんですけどまぁやりたいことがそこにあってそこにえぐい行く以外にそれを叶える
方法がないと実現できない
じゃあ行くしかないよねっていう形で決断していきました
でここに行き着くまでに本当にいろいろなことがあったんですけどその中でもあること
がすごく感じてその感じたことが今の僕の
活動の中核を担っています
それがこれですスポーツは人生を豊かにする
おっ
スポーツの力って本当にすごいなぁと思うんですよ
あのドイツではアマチュアのチーム選手であっても普段の練習からめちゃくちゃ一生
懸命でめちゃくちゃ激しいんですよ
本当に練習中に t シャツ敗れるとか日常茶飯地で
で
あの忙しい中でも週末に試合があるときの皆必ず予定をつけて試合に来てみんなで勝つ
為に一生懸命戦って試合が終わったらこいつで見慣れているので
プレイのこととかプライベートのこととかいろんなことを話し合います
そして観客の方も本当に何百円なんですけど
入場料を払って試合を見に来てくれて試合を見ながらビールを飲んで
みんなで正しい話をしながら応援をしてというのが一般的になっています
あの本当に
僕は日本に行った時にドイツに行く前までは全くもビールも何にもお酒はまったく飲ま
なかったんですけど
こうやってねあのビールを飲みながらみんなといろんな話をしたりとか
楽しむっていうことが何て言うのかな本当に人生を豊かにする
楽しみの方法の一つなんだなーっていうことをすごい感じてあのこれ以来ずっとあの
仲間とビールを飲みながら話す時間というのがすごい好きになりました
なので今でもいわゆるノミュニケーション大好きです
high rate もちろんこういうアマチュアの大会だっても地域の企業さんが
すごくサポートをしてくれていて
試合会場ではイベントをやったりとか本当に地域一体となってみんなでそのスポーツを
楽しんでいるっていう文化に触れたのはすごくいい経験になりました
そして
まあプロのチームでやっていたのでプロの選手とたくさんお話しする機会があったん
ですけどすごく印象的な話があって
ある選手が言ってたんですけど
あのドイツって結構あの
仕事をしながらハンドボールをするということが一般的なんですねプロの選手であって
も仕事を並行してやるっていうことが一般的で
なんて仕事してるのって話をしたら
ハンドボールだけで一生稼げる選手ってまあ本当にごくごく一部だよね
ね仕事をしながら確かに大変なんだけど仕事をしている時ってハンドボール以外で人と
して成長できる場面がたくさんあるからすごくやりがいがあるんだと
でスポーツしてハンドボールもしてっていう風なでハンドボールをやっていない時間が
あるから
ハンドボールをやったときにすごく集中できるんだよって話を聞いたときに
もうほんとにスポーツとか自分がやっていることに対する考え方とか
とらえ方がまったく違うんだなあっていうのは本当にその時に感じて
ん
でしれません
でその時に越冬日本でもこうやってもっとスポーツを使って
人生を豊かにする楽しめる方法ってないのかな
人生を楽しむためにスポーツてツールの一つでいいんじゃないかなということをすごく
考えるように感じるようになりました
不思議なことにこう日本を一回そっとにから見るとですね
日本ってメッチャクチャいいとこいっぱいあるんですよ
でやっぱりこう日本の良いところはこういうところ良い高いとかいいなぁこういうと
思ってよくしたらいいなというふうに外からすごく見えるようになって日本のことが
すごく大好きになりました
日本のためにもっと何ができないかな日本がいい国になるためにもっと何か出来ないか
なっていうのを少しずつ考えるようになって
じゃあ
そのときに僕に何ができるんだろう
と考えた時に
僕は現役を引退してそのいるチームで2年間くらいですかね
クラブのスタッフとして働きながら
チームのその運営とか経営に関することも勉強しながら
やっていました
2016年の2月から僕は日本に帰ってきて今は日本でハンドボールチームの運営経営
の方に関わっています
で僕が今はそのチームにいる中ですごく大事にしていることがあってそれは仲間を作る
こと
仲間を増やすこと
そしてその仲間と楽しむことですこれをすごく大事にしています
で僕らのチームでは
いわゆるサポーターって言いますよねスポーツ応援している人たちサポーターの人たち
のことを僕のチームでは shooters っていう名前で呼んでいます
昨シーズンなんですけどそのシューターズの方からのこの行動というか提案で
すごい感動したというかまぁ嬉しいことがでそれをちょっと今観ていただけたらなぁと
思うんですけど
おっ
えーとこれは昨シーズンのリーグ戦の終盤の時期でハンドボールって上位4チームが
日本一を懸けて戦うと鈴を振っていう大会に出れるんですねそのプレーオフをかけて
いけるかなどうかなというきわどい試合の中でエコれ首位のチームに大差でボロ負けし
ちゃった後の映像なんですよ
ねみんながこうちょっと沈んでいる中で上げちゃったら大丈夫かなぁっていう雰囲気の
中であるシューターズの方がまだまだプレーオフの可能性があるんだから
みんなで1つになってその可能性を求めましょうを求めましょう
みんなでひとつになりましょうみんなでミーティングジャンプをしましょうって言って
くれて
本当に僕らからではなくて shooters の方からの提案で
選手だけではなく選手と観客の皆さんと一緒に一つになって何かを成し遂げれた瞬間
だったのでこれは本当にいいなんて言うのかなもうやっててすごく好
やりがいを感じだというか幸せを感じたというかなんかマナーありがたみ
感じた瞬間でした
そして
これがその shooters って形のまあ本当にごく一部の方の写真なんですけど
この方達も応援をする前って全く知らない人たちだったんですよ
そんな人たちが応援を通じてこうやってみんなで仲間になって言って僕らの仲間にも
なってくれたんですね
で僕はもちろん三重県なんで僕らのホームゲームというのは三重県であるんですけど
毎試合三重県まで
この中の一人は岡山から
一緒に来てくれてて
ちょっとも crazy だなと思ってたんですけど本当にありがたいなぁという
気持ちと本当に仲間なんだなっていうのをすごく感じてもちろんあの他県の方からも方
もたくさん見えてはいたんですけど本当にありがたい仲間だなというふうに今も感じて
います
そして僕らはこういった仲間を仲間と楽しくやっていきたいなぁというところとこう
いう仲間をもっともっと増やしたいなという活動の
しています
例えばこれは試合中のハーフタイムにある時間を使って地域の団体さんにその時間を
使っていただいて普段練習していることを披露する場所として使っていただけました
これちょっとかわいいワンちゃんの写真なんですけどこれはあのある団体さんとの
コラボレーション企画だったんですけどその団体さんというのは保健所に預けられる犬
とかねこう一時的に預かって
で砂糖衣を探すっていう団体さんなんですね
試合会場前でその団体さんと一緒にですね佐藤朝霞市
も当然したんですけどその際にですね
今日本でこういう問題があるんだよとかこういうところをみんながこうしないように
しようねみたいな話をたくさんすることもできていろんな方にそういったことも知って
いただく機会として利用していただきました
こういった活動を通じてですね僕らは本当にもっともっと三重県の仲間を一緒に作って
いきたいですしもっと三重県を誇れる場所にしていけたらいいなというふうに思って
活動をしています
そしてですね僕が今日ちょっと皆さんにお話をしたかったことを皆さんにということ
だったところっていうのがこれです
スポーツで丸々を幸せにしよう
で今日はあのお越し頂いたみなさんがスポーツのイメージとか見方がちょっとでも
変わって帰って頂けたらうれしいなというふうに思っています
ちなみに皆さんスポーツのイメージってどんなことをお持ちですか
中あります
こういった如何思うよねとか
感動を多くの人に届けられるよねとか
例えばやる側の立場に立つと一生懸命努力することを学べるよねーとかそんなところが
割と一般的なのかなと思うんですけど僕が
考えているというか僕が思うすごく大事なスポーツの力って
多くの人を集められることなんですよ
どういうことかというと多くの人が集まるということはそこで必ず
経済活動が行われます
例えば
試合会場に来る際に公共交通機関の利用が増えるねとか
例えば試合会場の周辺の飲食店の利用が増えるねーとか
そういった所って本当にこのチームが地域にある
すごい大きな魅力そして影響力だと思うんですね
多くの人が集まるところにはそういうビジネスチャンスっていうのも多く生まれてき
ます
よく言われる地域が地域じゃんすいません
スポーツが地域を元気にするっていう言葉がよく使われると思うんですけど
そういった意味合いも含まれていていわゆるこれがスポーツ産業とか
スポーツビジネスというところに当たるかなと思っています
そして
プレイヤー側
プレイをする側の話でいくと僕がねすごく大事だったんだなとか
すごくこれてよかったなと思うことは
失敗することなんです
失敗することを僕を覚えたんで今本当に自分の今ここに立つ出るのはそれを覚えられた
からだなというのをすごく感じるんですけど
スポーツって本当に短い0コンマ何秒の中でいろんな選択肢の中から
一つ正しい選択をしてそれを行動に移さなきゃいけないんですよ
これってあのビジネスの面でもすごく通ずるところがあると思うんですけど
ただそれのその選択の連続なんです
なんで毎回毎回正しい選択ができるわけではないんですよ
むしろ逆で失敗ばっかりのです
その失敗をしていく中でその失敗をいかに成長させていけるかとか改善して次良いもの
にしていくらくいけるかというところがすごく重要で
そこを学べたのは僕はすごく大きかったです
そうですちょっと違った観点で見るとまたスポーツも違うとこに見えるかなと思うん
ですけど
あのそれこそ別の点で言うとスポーツの中でチームビルディングだったらチーム
マネジメントというところでいくと
なかなかモチベーション上がらない団体に属してたりとか
この団体の中でみんなが助け合うフォローし合える関係性が作れてないなーとかって
いう問題って皆さん抱えていると思うんですけど
そういったところも学べるいい場所かなと僕は思ってます
でスポーツって本当に皆さん子供の頃から
何の違和感もなくスッと
やれますよね
そのスポーツを見方を変えることで本当に人生を豊かにするツールの1つとして使って
いければどんどんどんどん高いろんな可能性というのが広まっていくんじゃないかなと
僕は考えています
なので僕が今この中でスポーツで丸々を幸せにしよ
これにあてるとするとスポーツで今彼はクラブに関わっている人たち全ての人を幸せに
したいです
そしてそんなのはをもっともっと広げていきたいです
であの最初にありました僕ハンドボールが好きだから幸せなんじゃないよっていう話も
したと思うんですけど僕にとってハンドボールって
自分の人生そして誰かの人生を幸せにツールのひとつです
では
ちょっと長くなりましたが最後にもう一度だけ
同じ質問させてください
皆さん人生に楽しいですか
僕は人生めっちゃ楽しいですただめっちゃしんどいです
もしこの質問に今即答できないなあという人がもしこの中にいれば是非ごスポーツを
使ってスポーツを利用して自分の人生そして誰かの人生を幸せにしてみませんか
このマルマルに入るところに自分で誰か何かを当てはめて実際その人のために行動して
みてください
きっと人生の何かが変わると思います
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]